c'est connu les canadiens consomment
trop de sel est trop de sucre avec des
conséquences désastreuses pour la santé
dieu a dit sur cinq vivent avec au moins
une des maladies chroniques les plus
courantes comme les marques les maladies
cardiaques ou les diabètes et là où ça
ne va plus c'est que les chiffres
augmentent selon la ministre et surtout
chez les jeunes
il fallait donc agir santé canada s'est
d'abord attaqué au gras trans ses
nouvelles cibles sont maintenant le sel
et le sucre
la ministre entend exiger un étiquetage
sur les aliments qui définira leur
valeur nutritive
elle veut consulter les canadiens au
cours des prochaines semaines sur les
meilleurs symboles à adopter avec ou
sans pictogrammes mais en gardant dans
l'esprit que la dose maximum de sel de
sucre et de gras sera établie à 15 %
hélène laurendeau nutritionniste voit
cette mesure d'un bon oeil ce qui est
important c'est que ça se retrouve sur
le devant de l'emballage pas sur le côté
pas l'arrière pas et est donc ce je
pense que ça va peut-être aidé certains
aliments seront toutefois exemptés de
l'obligation d'afficher un symbole
nutritionnel par exemple les viandes
crues les aliments vendus dans les
marchés
le lait ainsi que les huiles végétales
les entreprises auront jusqu'en 2022
pour s'adapter
certains spécialistes comme les
cardiologues martin juneau trouve que
c'est trop long cinq ans c'est trop long
il va il va en avoir pas mal
d'augmentation d'obésité diabète et
maladies cardiovasculaires dans les cinq
années qui viennent
tous pense quand même que le
gouvernement va dans la bonne direction
ils attendent maintenant de voir si ces
mesures seront reflétés dans le nouveau
guide canadien sur l'alimentation
attendus au cours des prochaines
semaines et c'est catherine kovacs radio
canada montréal